那么以及
第第三第12这个里面的一个实现啊
重点今天的重点呢是D3
D12里面的一个实现啊
R9R前面的呢它很简单
我们就是了解一下就可以了
慢慢的以后我们会越来越熟悉它的哈
那首先是从IHI层面的命令开始看起
那么它首先有这么一个结构体
就是一个hi man base的命令的一个积累
那么它就两个
一个是一个next的指针
有了这个next的指针
我们就可以把它构成一个链表
就是一个command
链接着下一个command
又链接着下一个command形成链表
然后还有一个虚函数
就是说具体去执行这个hi com它的一个方法
那么具体的执行就代表了不同类型的这个I
hi q mp不同的渲染命令
所以它是个虚函数
到真正的子函数里面去执行
那么它还有下面
马上还是做了一个子类的一个帮助
就是说他可以轻易的将一个LAMBD存储起来
然后去调用
你看它是一个模板类
那么它传入一个lambda的参数
它的构造函数里面会传入这个lambda函数
然后把它保存起来
然后等他真正执行的时候
实际上就去执行这个lambda的这个函数
执行完了以后就把这个lambda给释放掉
那么以后我们就可以通过有了它以后
我们就可以轻易的根据一个lambda把它传进来
就构成了一个那个hi的一个渲染命令
好
然后还有一个啊对
就是他这个i hi command呢继承了他
然后也是一个模板类
这个其实一般就是它的子类
然后传进来呢其实可以看到它只是调用子类
本身是一个sq and destruction函数
它其实转接变成调用一个sq的方法
然后调用完之后把它释放掉
那这个影响不大
我们一看就可以了解了
好有了这几个基础
它就可以在这个基础上去定义各种各样的操作
比如说我们看到它的实现啊
这里就有一堆
我们去找几个
那比如说这个这个一看名字就知道了
SC的PANAMETER就是设置SEDER的参数
那么他就继承了一个渲染命令啊
它是个模板类
那么实际上他就是会去实现一个execute的方法
那当然了
他去保存了他这些必要的参数
C的啊
以及这个index啊之类的
那么它实际上在执行的时候
那就是他其实这个就是实现一个execute方法
实际上就是去调用一个IHICC
POMMETER的函数
那么就真正的去调到i hi里面的那个函数
然后这个HI一般都会在每一个平台
比如说D3D12
open gl等等去实现它的子类
然后在子类里面去真正的去触发那个渲染命令
然后这个红的一般就是其实把它展开
一般就是get到这个这个上下文context
然后就掉它的这个函数哈
其实就是调查好
这里我们看到有两个两个两个关键的东西
就是LI一个命令的列表
还有一些context就是上下文
那么命令的链表呢
其实就是把刚才那个命令组装成一个链
表的一个类
那么上下文呢就是说你执行一个命令
有时候是需要不同的一些呃
上下文的就是一些当前的状态的
你在不同的地方
比如说你是用用哪个command list啊
去去调用这些参数
那么这个context里面呢就就对应的这些信息
一般都是这样
就这样子
然后这个content是在D3D12里面
也是有具体的子类去实现的
那这个就是这个红
有了这几个
那这里我们再看浏览
你可以感兴趣可以浏览一下
这里有很多子类哈
比如说什么sex dl啊
就是测试这个STL的参数
C某呃
这些什么C德的参数
uniform Buff啊
以及很多很多啊
什么UUAVSAV之类的东西
还有什么什么SASAMPLE
seto simper啊之类
就是说那这里有几百行啊
从这里各种各样哈
他其实在在这里面
就实现了各种各样常规的那个渲染命令
把它构建成一个子类
那么那个list我们看一眼
OK这个呢就是command list哦
我们看下他的贝斯
看他他是继承一个command space的鸡肋哈
啊对他好
这个呢就是将刚才那一堆命令
组装成一个链表的参数
那么这里我们关注两个地方
一个呢是它的成员变量再滚下来
在这里他就这这里有两个指针
第一个呢是一个common base的指针root
那么它其实就是记录了整个命令列表的
第一个命令
root就是第一个命令
然后每个命令它都有一个next的指针
然后就形成一个链表
所以它就可以找到所有的命令
那这个呢是一个指针的指针
那它其实是什么呢
它其实是最后一个command的
那个next的那个变量的地址
为什么
因为当我们要把一个新的命令添加进来的时候
我们要要怎么样要在最后那里把它添加进去
那一种方法
你可以从root里面一直一直一个外循环
找到最后一个命令
然后把最后一个命令的NEX去指向新的
那这样你要便利一次
那这个呢就不用
我本身就每次的更新
存储着最后一个命令的那个next
然后直接把它设置进去就可以了
这就是这个
然后我们看一下它还提供了几个最关键的方法
比如说新建一个命令
就是这个allocation command这个
那这个就是我们刚才说的
就是新建一个命令的时候会怎么样
它本身就是从内存里面去申请一个命令
一个移动内存
然后呃记录数据加一是吧
然后你看这个本身就是在当前最后一个命令的
那它是一个指针的指针对吧
然后把它设直线
我们现在新增的
那么就是把它原本最后一个指针的那个next
指向了这个新的命令
那么这个新的命令是不是就串起来了
串起来了
然后这个注意现在那现在把它加进来
那他这个就变成了最后一个命令
所以要更新一下这个art的next更新给他
那下次他就会一直类似的去操作
那么这样子就是当他在allocate这个命令的时候
它自动的就已经添加到这个command
list的这个里面哈
就是我们在别的地方
如果你看到代码诶
怎么只是只是新建新建了一个命令
但是你看不到他是怎么样
因为他是自动的加到这个列表里面的哈
当你调这个函数
它就自动了
好
它下面还实现了一个模板类
就是呃一个任意的模板啊
本来就是调查的时间
然后下面这个方法呢
就是呃你不用新建一个命令的类的去继承
你直接告诉我一个LAMBA的方法
那比如说我们在别的地方
如果你见过
那么就是一个ink
然后什么什么什么command command
然后就就传入一个lambda函数
那其实就是他
那当他把一个lambda的传进来的时候
他其实这个就是立即执行的模式啊
一般就是走下面这个分支
那其实就是去新建一个lambda的模板类
把这个lambda存储起来
然后这个allocate其实就是调上面的函数哈
你看其实就是调一个这个allocate的函数
就是调这个函数
所以当他调这个函数的时候
它就自动的添加到这个列表里面了哈
注意这里只是把命令
创建并添加到列表里面
那GPU有没有真正的执行啊
没有哈
GPU现在还没有真正的执行
那在这个IHI层面的执行是怎样子的呢
那么当然也很简单
就是便利一下这个链表去执行就OK了
那么就是这个command lix的execute的方法
这个SK的方法我们看一下
那呃
那就是这个在最后呃
不管哪边都一样的
那就是它首先它定义了一个迭代器哈
这个迭代器就是自动的
帮你不断的更新到一个next哈
就是一个iterator
这个你看就是一个不断的直接下一个哈
就是说它实际上就是一个外循环
那先定一个
然后就外循环
外循环就是相当于是从root开始不断的去迭代
然后每个命令就去执行
他执行这个execute and destruction的方法
然后遍历循环执行完
那么这保存起来的这个所有的命令就执行了
就触发了他的执行哈
那么sq的方法有些很简单
这个呢就是common lix的一个关键的一个
封装的思路哈
那么在这个基础上
common lix的基础上
它实际上还会继承一些两个类哈
比如说呃computer hi come
那么这个就是计算
则是先它就在这个基础上去呃
定义一些计算折射器相关的一些常见的接口
那比如说他会加这些什么方法
你看什么c uniform Buff是吧
cc的uniform buffer这些哈
还有还有什么build的uniform buffer哈
就是它会定在这个基础上
把一些常见的操作也定义在这里面来
那你看比如说他下一个seed的参数它是怎么样
它其实就是新建一个cc的参数的命令哈
其实它并不是真的去调用啊
并不是真的去调用GPU啊
真的去设置
而只是他把这个方法里面
本质其实是新建一个命令到那个root里面哈
你想真正的去触发
你还要调那个Q的方法哈
那么在这个基础上呢
还还有两个子类
就是说继承了他的一个是computer
另外一个呢就是common lix的爱
hi ka lex哈
嗯还有一个immediate呃
我们先看看
这个呢它是继承computer
那么它定义了更多哈
因为因为computer
它一般来说就不是不是一些图形的
它是一些计算相关的
那么这个就是图形的
那么有了图形的
那就会定义这些什么什么这些什么
resource的一些操作啊
uniform的一些操作啊
C的操作这个参数的操作哈
那我们其实现在的留留意到啊
它一般很多函数哈
它它还会真正的实现是调一个context
去去去执行的哈
它并不是说在那个dynamic r h r i哈
我们前面看到说有很多平台的操作
是在dynamii hi的
但是有一些是contents
那有什么不同呢
一般来说哈呃在dynamic i hi里面定义的呢
就是说一般就是直接device
就是D3d device
直接就可以定义对应的一些操作
就是跟你当前的上下文当前的状态是没关联的
那么如果跟当前的有关联
那么比如说我们知道在D3
D12里面的所有的操作哈
都是一个common list的对应的方法哈
那么它其实就是会用这个context去调用呃
没所谓哈
你只你只要了解一下
他大部分时候都是调调contest里面的
有有的接口吧
所以呢他在i hi层面呢
又定义了各种各样的这样子的方法
还在common里面哈
那么还有另外一个呢
就是后面加一个immediate的的子类
那这就是一个立即立即模式哈
其实就是呃例子就是不是等一下再操作的
而是立立刻就操作的哈
他就是继承他
然后去定义这些哈
当然它本质上也是去去调用这些命令哈
AOK就是命令它本质上
比如说一个in queen lambda
我们最常见的外面就是它了哈
就是你常见的是不是一个什么inquent command
一个类似的一个宏
然后你传一个lambda参数进来
实际上就会调用到它哈
调用到它
然后实际上就是在它里面去创建一个这样子的
command的一个对象
并添加到那个量表里面
然后这个对象就是保存着你这个lambda
等他最后去执行那个sq的方法的时候
就会for外循环执行每一个命令的sq的方法哈
呃我们看一下
最后看一下那个context
那就是IIHI嗯
Come on
OK这个就是那个context呃
它一样
它是继承computer
conteputer con呃
这就是定义了一些computer相关的
比如说什么set CD的参数啊
transaction u v v s这些东西哈
samba这些参数定义了很多哈
还有这些FX的操作
然后
command的基础上呢就定义了更多哈
呃
那比如说什么
这个是computer
比如说它对应的就是computer
shader command的
一般就是古拉菲seed的哈
格拉菲seed的
那他一样会有这些定义了很多hr的这些操作哈
那它当然都是虚函数
真正的实现是在第3D里面去实现的哈
那这些了解一下
那么这样子在RHI层面的
它就是定义它
总
它本质上来说就是有所有的东西
是在那个command list里面的
command list里面也有一个context的成员变量
然后呢
有的东西呢就是直接在那个dynamii hi
里面定义的
一般来说一些什么create之类的的操作呢
就是叫dynamir gr里面定义的
因为它是跟上下文无关的
你比如说你要clay一个一个texture
或者是GA一个呃papi day
那这种操作是跟当前上下文无关的
一般就是在dynamic hr里面去定义
但是你比如说你要设置一个SHADER的参数
那你是在哪个pipeline里面去设置哪个command
在第三第12的common里面去设置这个东西
那就是有不同的上下文的哈
那么就一般都定义在现在这个这个context里面
但不管你是dynamic h i还是context
这些东西都收拢到common list里面
common list里面就维护着一个队列
记录着所有的command
然后common的子类里面其实就是调用这些方法好
但是我们千万不要以为你真的去执行了哈
他在D32的实现里面还有一个封装好
这个是在这个层面上
IHI层面的封装
我们现在具体的去以D3
D12去看下它的封装框架
那么我们直接先看它的device嗯
Device
比如说是def d3D12device
OK这个类
因为所有东西对吧
都是从device出发的
我们看一下这个类的实现呃
第一
那就是D3D12的DIY是真正的D是吧
在这里面
然后呃
他有我们还记得D3D12的
一些常见的几个关键的吗
第一个是一个common queen
是不是一个queen的强调
养好有一个command command lix对吧
我们比如说平时设置一个顶点
设置一个顶点或者是一个索引的缓冲
其实是要调第三题12的那个command list里面的sex
什么logic buffer的那种参数
那么所以其实它是要那个command queen
command list的一些对吧
那么其实在这个D3D12里面
他就有这个common k
而且还不止一个
我们往下翻嗯
大概在哪里呢
看一下这个
对对对对
这个
呃这个D3D12的queen其实就是对应封装呃
D3D12里面的那个common queen哈
就是
这个哈这个这个可不可
那注意到我们device里面每一个D3
D12device里面它不是一个queen
它是一个数组
实际上一般就是三个
因为它是个枚举值
我们看一下他的那个枚举值的定义
比如说它定义了几个queen的类型
它一般就是定义了三种
一个是DLTE
一个是copy的
一个是异步的SYNC的
实际上它就是三种
那么整个数组其实就是三个
它其实就是三个
三个不同的可以用来做不同的操作
一个device对应三个queen
然后它它相关的很多东西都都是对应哈
比如说context
刚才我们说不是有context上下文吗
看这几个
那么你做不同的操作
它也有不同的context
你比如说你要是做一个copy的操作
还是做一些异步的操作
那其实就是调都不同的
常见的我们那个graphic的操作
很多的是调这个的
然后还有一个另外一个单独的就是immediate
立即执行模式
它也是一个单独的context
实际上
所以我们说
为什么在上层要调那个context的来执行呢
是因为你你具体是在不同的那个DX的
上下文里面去执行这个操作的哈
它就是定义了三种哈
定义了三种
每个都是对应每一个模组值啊
它现在有三种
所以这个数组的就是有三个哈
然后然后还有对应的这个什么heap
它也是三个二
这个代码它直接就是填三了哈
这个U1官方他也直接就就是个三啊
那它不像这个啊
这个就是直接用这个这个count这个值定义哈
它直接就写死了哈
以及相关了
那这个就是上下文
那我们可以看一下context是什么东西
context里面到底包含了哪些东西
我们跳到这个类里面去看呃
它里面有什么东西
我们看一下它的成员变量
中间有很多函数吧
等下回过头再看一眼
诶过了吗
诶他应该有个command lix的成员变量
0game
哦是不是在common里面
啊对对对对
他是在基类父类里面的
因为它它是继承了这个common的
其实呢它其实里面就是包含了一个上下文
就是对应了他的一个command
Command or locator
以及这个PAYLOPO
就是一个数组
就是一组的工作哈
一组的命令
这个我们稍后再看
这个也很重要哈
还有一个数据是哪里呢
什么state
FD3D12的一个state
嗯难道不在这里在这里吗
啊对对对
有一个缓存cash是day cash呃
为什么很重要呢
因为即使你从i hi层面调用了execute
其实在D3D12里面也还不是立刻执行
好
在D3D12里面也不是立刻执行啊
因为我们看一下它的函数
到时候就知道了
好我们还有刚才那个披露
我们来看一下那个配乐啊
先别着急
呃我们跳到那个这个这个类
这里这个类这个类我们先看一下
它很重要
它本身就是一个
有一个链表
有个宿主
看到没
它本身其实也是存储着一组的command
他并没有真的去去掉那个common
它也是缓存起对应的那个command
到最后才执行那么一个plow
其实什么他的注英文注释就很简单了
就是一个payload
就是一个work
就是一个GPU里面要操作的一些东西要去执行的
那么它其实里面就有一些有个queen
就是用来到到时候是在哪个queen里面执行的
然后它其实存储了一个数组的common list
然后还有一些对应的那些FX
就是你执行这些命令要对应的一些等待的操作
那么这个payload就是他嗯
那比如说我们回过头来那个还有那个stay catch
在contents里面定义的对
这个是什么呢
就是我们知道整个渲染管线它是有很多状态的
比如说光栅化的一些状态
是单手的一些状态
你你可能反反复复的设置了很多是
那么这个时候他并没有真正的样地
地下12的GPU立刻去执行它
其实在地下12里面的封装
它做了一个steak状态的一个缓存
意思很明显
就是你明显你上传要调用某个设置状态的东西
我只是把这个状态先存储起来
到最后我一次性全部设置
所以呢他在这个STCS里面呢
就保存着所有的信息呃
就是很多了
你看它这里面的这些变量超级多的
呃他有一个方法就是去执行哈
嗯应该是apply
OK这是它的一个函数
在这个state cash里面
它有一个apply
对我们看这个apply
对插这个函数就能就可以明白了
就是去
标记一下
标记一下是不是都停了
然后呢会执行什么
会执行
Common lix
那我们看下
比如说他会拿出
PS和pipeline state的一些信息
你是computer的还是GRAPHID
就拿出对应的topus day
然后呢会去设置它的跟签名
前面上一次我们已经讲了跟签名
然后就会去真正的去设置这个跟签名的常数
然后呃一些
顶点的缓存
然后限制这些VIEWPORT
你看到这里他才是真正的去这个呢
就是已经真正的是D3D12的那个common list了哈
真正的去设置哈
那这个是GRAF的操作哈
那比如说去设置就是VIP啊
这些什么什么sr six啊
这些三角形啊
bland呀
step3啊
他给啊
各种各样的参数
然后去比如说包括SAMA啊
它其实里面就是真的去执行哈
比如说嗯呃到那真正的去执行啊
这些东西哈
看到没真的去把它设置进去
也就是说这个是stay cash
它定义了两层的两层的结构
一层呢就是先保存所有的数据
第二层呢在apply里面去
真正才是去掉第三第12的东西去实现哈
嗯我们再看一下这个类
它有很多变量哈
比如说啊这些是不是设置啊
还有这个结构体
这个结构体呢就是graphics day
那你看什么STLE啊
blame的参数啊
然后VIEWPORT的参数啊
然后还有XO啊
你看这个注释
然后还有index啊
三角形啊
然后输入啊啊
还有这些graphic state
还有这些pipeline day
还有这些SRVCVVVSIRAPSO对吧
他很多城市其实他已经就相当于是把整一个嗯
渲染管线
所有的东西都缓存起来
包括C的在哪里
包括那些跟签名
包括那些uniform buffer
它全部都缓存起来嗯他还死
然后到最后他比如说你设一个vie炮
我们看他下一个view p
他其实只是把这个VIP的东西存储起来而已
你看到没有
只是把它存储起来而已
这个memory copy只是把它存储起来而已
他真的去掉那个色色了吗
没有他在apply的时候才会真的去设置
那这个呢就是呃大概的流程就是这样哈
在一个device
第3D的device里面有三种三套context
一个是什么啊
CCOPY的一个是异步的ASYNC的
一个是DELECT
有三套
也就是说你这个操作是在哪个上下文去执行的
然后在上下文里面那个context里面
它就有这些变量
有这个stay cash
比如说我们看回过头来去看CONTEX
Ok context
因为我们说在i hi前面的context定义了很多操作
那么在第三第12里面去实现
它就是中间这一堆中间这一对
那么在IHI层面去实现
它也必还不是真正的去那个哈
这个是HI里面去去那个去那个
这个是D3D12里面的那个哈
你看你比如说你要设置一个seed的sample sample
他其实只是把这个sample了
设置到这个stay cash里面而已
看到没有
只是设置到这个STCS里面而已
这些全部操作都是哈
比如说你算什么啊
这也是算什么
它就是根据不同的
你是哪个哪一种类型
你是顶点着色器
它就是设置到顶点着色器的里面
你是max c的
就设置到里面
诸如此类
比如说你像这些什么呃
SRV的参数
它也只是保存在那个STCATCH里面而已
当然了
你从IHI前面的角度
你可以不用理
你可以不用关注你
i hi前面的角度
只要你sq了
你就认为他已经在执行了
对你没有影响了
但是这是D3D12里面
他自己内部的又实现了一套这样子的东西
因为什么
因为它是在另外一个单独的线程里面去操作的
就是这个D3D12里面
它其实又是在一个单独的线程里面
你各种各样的地方
其他的线程
比如说hi渲染线程
render线程里面调用了各种HI的命令
最终提交到D3D12里面了
D3D12里面只是把它缓存起来
然后在D3D12里面的那个线程
它每一帧就会apply一下就掉
这个cast apply就才是真正的去执行一次
那么这个东西是从哪里来的呢
那个县城是哪里呢
那就是呃
我们可以看一下那个dnm i hi的一个函数额
大概叫initial是吧
我们看下
Mission
OK应该是在这个hi层面
这个函数
你看这个呢是在整个引擎一开始初始化的时候
就会初始化的一个函数
它其实是做了一个new了一个县
县城new了一个线程
这个线程就是去这个函数执行这个函数
你看一下他
那他就是
对于每一个queen
对于每个queen这个FH是怎么操作的呢
它其实就是拿到这个device
然后对于每一个device里面的每一个queen
刚才我们说一个device里面是不是有三个queen啊
然后每个queen里面都会掉这个这个回调函数
那就是外面的就是这个函数
也就是说他其实每一帧不断的在那里
执行这个process
这个process实际上就会遍历所有的device
每个device里面的三个命令队列queen
然后去执行这个操作
然后实际上就会拿出他的披露所有的PAYLO
我们刚才说配漏就是组装了一组一组command list
是不是里面是有一个common list的数组
所以呢实际上就是把这个play lo
额执行一下
看看在哪里执行的
这些都是准备工作准备工作
应该是EXEQ吧
这应该有个什么EQ
就比较厚吧
每一个payload
然后check这个GPU
要拿出这个device
这些是事件处理
然后这些and all tall
这些还不是
难道就嗯
看look on queen
应该是有一个sq
看漏了吗
认真一点
Come on queen
这么神奇不对不对
我找一下
搜一下搜一下
我不信
应该是
当前文档
对啊有啊啊啊哦
刚才没看到这个东西吗
在这里
是跳错了吗
Process some mix
对呀
诶刚才好像跳错了哦
刚才跳跳错东西了
我刚才可能看错了吗
OK那我们新建的那个那个县城啊
县城就是调这个process of mix哦
他是in the lab
在这个在这个分支
哦跳错了没事
那个应该就是哦这个是INTERLAB模式
这个是some mix
OK我们看这个看这个
呃它实际上就是便利每一个queen
然后拿出他的披露
然后掉这个在下面
在下面
去
这很像面
Execute
那就是execute
这个payload就是execute这个配乐
我们看一下
它
其实就是把这个PAYO里面的那个command list拿出来
这个是那个TAYO
然后有个for循环
把所有的command list
把所有的COMMANX添加到里面去
然后再执行execute
就是它那不管上下都是一个sq
就是说一个配漏
一个配漏
就是一个数组
一个common list的数组
然后for循环for循环所有去执行它
中间呢这里有一个长强度稍微超强一点呢
为什么呢
就是说因为他解释也很清楚啊
就是当你的command list太多的时候
你一次性去提交
就是调这个函数
一次性去提交command的时候
如果这个数量太多
那么GPU是会会不支持的
会有异常的
会有bug
那么这个时候呢
它其实就是说如果你payload里面确实太多了
那么他就先执行一半
就是说因为因为这里提提交的是一个offset嘛
那我就就记记着你这个offset
然后提交的数量
我就先把前面一段数量太多了
我就先把其中的一段先提交这个sq了
然后接着来
这不是一个循环吗
因为没走完
所以又把接着剩下的又继续往里面提交换
就是这么一个流程
然后呃最后就会执行完了
就为历史这个这个common list哈
就历史这个common lise
历史的话它其实只是回收到这个queen里面
KIM里面是有是有一个object的
就是有一个直的哈
就是其实把它放回进去
就是重复利用的
就是在cream里面的这个PO里面有个数组链表
那么它其实释放的时候就会把它放回去啊
到时候拿出来的药的时候就是从这里拿哈
你看update的时候
当你外部A说我需要一个新的command的时候
它其实要么就是从里面破一个出来
如果没有
那第一次那就会new一个
不然就是真的就把它pop出来
然后就给外面用了
外面用
就比如说你现在去构建一个新的payload的时候
需要一个common list
那就从这里拿出来
然后给它
所以它实现了一个呃这样子的重复利用哈
就是你用完了就把它不许回去
那么到时候就又可以用这个历史啊
那么这个呢就是大概在D3D10里面的
一个命令的执行流程哈
那我们最后花几分钟来总结一下
第一它是在初始化的时候会新建一个线程
新建一个线程
new一个flag
然后他其实本地本本这个D3D12
它本身也是一个单独的线程
不断的在那里process
然后在D3D12的实现里面
每一个device是对应三个queen
三种不同类型的命令queen以及不同的context
然后当外面真的去提交
当上层i hi层面真的去提交一个
比如说set一个seed peameter
设置一个SHADER的参数的时候
它其实在D3D12里面
只是把这个东西存储起来
把common list存储起来
把对应的状态存储在那个stay cats的变量里面去
然后到真正的这个县城自己去去执行的时候
就会遍历所有的device
遍历每一个device的queen
然后遍历它的PAYLO
把他配漏的command lix拿出来
一次性全部执行
就是调它的apply
包括设置那些状态
那个STEAKY里面的设置
那么大概就是这么样一个流程好
那今天这个这个只是过了一遍
D 3d12
以及hi前面的这个命令的一个大体的封装思路
后面我们就可以在这个基础上去看
上层是如何一步一步的去组装
变成一个渲染的pass
以及最终多个pass怎么去实现渲染的整个流程哈
OK那今天我们就先讲到这里